اهلا بكم مشاهدينا انا راويه القاسم وهذه
العربيه 360 الخبر من كل زوايا هو من جميع
الجوانب
هو موضوع وراء وصول صانع قنبله لوكربيل
الى امريكا بعد الاعلان عن اختطافه من
ليبيا قبل اسابيع
وزير الخارجيه السعوديه يؤكد ان دول
المنطقه ستتحركوا لحمايه امنها اذا حصلت
ايران على سلاح النووي
قعد التاهل التاريخي للمغرب لمربع الذهبي
في المونديال العربيه 360 تستعرض لكم
ارقاما قياسيه لاسود الاطلس
[موسيقى]
وفي القضايا السياسيه التي شغلت مواقع
التواصل الاجتماعيه تتبعون ايضا
على خطى فيسبوك وتويتر لينك ان تحذف اكثر
من 21 مليون مستخدم من المنصه ضمن سياسه
مكافحه الحسابات المزيفه
[موسيقى]
عدد الولايات المتحده لتفتح ملف التفسير
لوكاربي باعلامها اليوم احتجازها ليبيا
يشتبه في قيامه بصنع القنبله التي استخدمت
في تفجير طائره امريكيه فوق لوكربي في
اسكتلندا في ديسمبر من عام
1988 ما اسفر عن مقتل 270
وزاره العدل قال ان ابو وعجيله محمد مسعود
موقوف وسيمثل امام قادم في العاصمه واشنطن
من دون تحديد تاريخ الموصوله وتعرض مسعود
المتهم بصناعه قنبله
الاختطاف في ليبيا الشهر الماضي
وظل مصيره حتى الاعلان عن احتجاجه في
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه
34 عاما مضت على اعلى في حادث ارهابي شهدت
الاراضي البريطانيه تفجير لاكر به الذي
راح ضحيته 270 شخصا لتبدا معها محطات
القضيه الابرص انطلاقا من عام 2003 حينما
اقرت ليبيا بمسؤوليتها عن حادث تفجير
اللكربي في اسكتلندا
توهاما بالضلوع في التخطيط وتصنيع قنبله
تتعلق بالارهاب لمواطن ليبي يدعى ابو عجيل
مسعود المريئي
امنعم الجاري فشاهده نوفمبر الماضي احداث
متسارعه اعاده قضيه اللقبي للواجهه بعد
الجدل الذي اثاره اختفاء ابو عجيل مسعود
في ظروف غامضه تقارير اعلاميه قالت انه
خططف من داخل السجن بالعاصمه طرابلس بينما
ظهر بيان وعائلته انه اختطف من منزله
ليطالب بعدها المجلس الاعلى للدوله حكومه
الوحده الوطنيه
بدور الكاميرا
عبر بيان اصدرته وزاره العدل تطرقت فيه
لرفضها فتح ملف قضيه
معلنه انه اغلق بالكامل سياسيا وقانونيه
لكن دون ان تتطرق للتهم الموجهه لها او
ملابسات اختفاء ابو عجيله
[موسيقى]
عائله ابو عجيله فكانت مناقضه لتلك
الرسميه عائلته قالت في بيان انه في
السادس عشر من نوفمبر الماضي اقتحم مسلحون
بملابس المدنيه منزلهم في العاصمه طرابلس
واختطفوا ابو عجيله وقت دوه لجهه غير
معلومه عزه اسرته وحينها اختطافها لاغراض
السياسيه ترمي الى الاضرار بالمصالح
العليا للبلاد
اخر محطه لغز اختفاء ابو عجينه كان في
ديسمبر الجاري بعد اعلان الولايات المتحده
ان المتهم المطلوب لديها ابو عجيله بترانا
الاحتجاز لديها دون ان توضح كيف وقع متهم
لكربي بقبضه
مواطنا ليبيا الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه ليحاكمه هناك بدايه هل هو اجراء
قانوني وهل فيه احراج للدوله الليبيه
اهلا بك حقيقه
ليبيا ااا تمنع بالقوانين الليبيه منعا
باتا تسليم اي مواطن ليبي لاي دوله خارج
ليبيا او لمثلا للقضاء خارج الدوله
الليبيه طبعا باستثناء الحالات التي يكون
فيها اتفاقيات لتبادل تسليم المجرمين او
السجناء ما بين ليبيا وبين دول اخرى ولكن
لا يوجد بين ليبيا وبين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه هذه الاتفاقيه حتى الان همم الى
مدى كبير جدا اعتقد ان عمليه تسليم همم
السيد همم ابو عجيله همم مسعود وهو ضابط
في المخابرات الليبيه ضابط سابق في
المخابرات الليبيه في عهد القذافي وكان
احد رموز النظام السابق كان همم مسجون
لمده سنوات في سجون السياسيه في ليبيا
تفرج عنه قبل فتره قريبه فقط
وكان يقيم بشكل فعلي في العاصمه طرابلس في
منطقه همم
اختفى قبل اس قليله جدا ظهرت اشاعه على
انه سيتم تسليمه الى الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وتفاجانا كما تفاجئ الجميع بان
هذه الشائعات حقيقيه يبدولي بان حدث تسليم
ابو عجيله همم الغريبه من نوعها تتعارض
بشكل قطعي مع القوانين الليبيه ربما هناك
من سيحاول تفسير عمليه من خلال ان هناك
همم اتفاقيه الدوليه مواقع لها ليبيا وهي
ما يتعلق بقيه المحاربه الارهاب قد تكون
هي المنفذ او القطار ربما
ابراهيم
السياسيه ما الدلالات من تسليم متهم همم
دخل الى السجن وخرج منه
بفعل تسويه عام 2008 بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وليبيا ما الدلالات السياسيه
واخراجه بهذا التوقيت بالذات ماذا تريد
الحكومه من ذلك
اولا هو نعم الحكومه الليبيه هي معنيه
بشكل مباشر ربما يوجه لها اصبع الاتهام
وتحتاج الان الى ان تتحدث الحكومه الليبيه
حكومه الوحده الوطنيه برئاسه الطيبه وايضا
النائب العام في هذه الحادثه يبدون لان
ربما يكون السيد عبد الحميد البيبه وهو
المعني او ربما المستفيد الاكبر من
التنبيش او نبش هذه القضيه التي اغلقت في
اتفاقيه وقعت ما بين الحكومه الليبيه وبين
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه في 14 اغسطس
2008 وبموجبها ان انتهى او اغلق ملف قضيه
لقربي بكل ما فيهم بان يشكل صندوق
للتعويضات
تعويضه». الان اعتقد ان هذه الحكومه
الحاليه حكومه الوحده الوطنيه تعاني من
موقف سياسي متخبط وربما هناك انحسار
لشرعيتها السياسيه على مستوى الدولي
وشرعيه الدوليه لهذه الحكومه ربما تحاول
الان او يحاول السيد الطيبه وحكمته همم
الحصول على بعض التاييد والدعم من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه حتى من خلال
تنبيش في
الملف صراحه التصريحات حتى الان من
الولايات المتحده الامريكيه سواء الحاليه
او السابقه تتعهد بان لا يفتح الا يفتح
قضيه لكرديه التي بصمات ايرانيه وبعض
الاطراف الاخرى واضحه جدا في هذه الحادثه
بجانب بعجيله وانا لا اعتقد انه هو نزيه
او بريء فعلا من الحادثه لان ضمن
اعترافاته قد يكون هناك همم حديث منه عن
ضلوعه ربما في في في مساله لوكربه من خلال
او في هذه الحادثه حادثه الطائره نفسها
ولكن ليس همم الطرف الاساسي والطرف
الحقيقي كان هناك متهمين وهمم وافرج على
الاول والثاني اخرج عنها لاسباب اخرى
لا اعتقد ان همم هذه المساله علاقه بشكل
مباشر باحداث القضيه مره اخرى يعني
هو محسوب على النظام السابق نعم وبالتالي
اذا كانت تقول بانه اصابع الاتهام وجهها
الان لي حكومه دبيبه في حال ثبت ذلك هل
ذلك يعني بانه دبيبه قد يضحي باسماء اخرى
مرتبطه بالنظام السابق مثل سيف القذافي
وغيرها من الاسماء
ربما تشجع عمليه تسليم بعجيله همم مسعود
باجلاء الضابط السابق في المخابرات
الليبيه وهو واحد قيادات النظافه همم بشكل
واضح ربما تشجع ربما اطراف اخرى في داخل
ليبيا وربما الحكومه نفسها في محاوله كسب
مواقف سياسيه
قد تذهب الى التضحيه فعلا او الى تسليم
شخصيات اخرى
واعتقد ان من بين الشخصيات حتى الان
الموجوده في السجن والتي يدور حولها حديث
من هذا النوع ربما عبد الله سنوسي ضد رئيس
المخابرات
العامه الليبيه السابقه
حتى سيف الاسلام لان ما زالت ملاحقات
الجنايات الدوليه موجوده حتى هذه اللحظه
اللي همم ضد سيف الاسلام اخشى من ان اا
عمليه تجاوز القانون بتسليم ليبيين الى
الخارج
وعمليه كسب ولاءات او كسب مواقف سياسيه قد
نعم الى مدى يصعد الاحتوائه في في مرحله
سابقه سيدفع اطراف سياسيه
وكتل موجوده داخل ليبيا لاخذ موقف ربما
يكون صدامي مع السلطات في حاله تستمر في
هذا في هذا النعج دون توضيح بشكل مباشر
لما يحدث شكرا جزيلا
لكاس اللي
[موسيقى]
بي في تحضير جديد وزير الخارجيه السعوديه
الامير فيصل بن فرحانه يؤكد ان فشل
الاتفاق النووي مع ايران سيدخل المنطقه في
مرحله خطيره جدا اردنا على سؤال حول
الاخفاء في التوصل الى اتفاق النووي مع
ايران ذكر وزير الخارجيه السعودي ان
المملكه ستواصل الدفعه نحو التوسل الى
اتفاق معتبرا ان الاتفاق المذكور حال
التوصل اليه هو مجرد خطوه اولى وليس اخيره
واضاف ان التوصل الى اتفاق النووي لا يعني
انه توجد ضمانات بان طهران لن تسعى الى
انتاج سلاح نووي وبشان احتمال توصل ايراني
الى انتاج سلاح نووي رد وزير الخارج
السعودي بان هذا يمكن ان يكون تطورا يهدد
امن المنطقه
[موسيقى]
بلا شكه هناك فرصه لكن هل التوصل الى
اتفاق النووي يعني ان ايران لن تصبح دوله
النوويه ولن يكون لديها سلاح نووي لا اعرف
انا اشك نحن نستمر بدعم التفاعل عبر
الاتفاق النووي وخطه عمل مشتركات ولكن هذه
نقطه بدايه وليست نقطه نهايه لمعالجه بعض
نقاط الضعف في الاتفاق البوادر غير
ايجابيه سمعنا من الايرانيين ان ليس لديهم
اي مصلحه في برنامج اسلحه النوويه ولكننا
بحاجه الى مزيد من الضمانات واذا لم نصل
الى اتفاق النووي سندخل في مرحله معقده
جدا وخطره وعلينا ان نتجنبها حتى لو عدنا
الى اتفاق النووي لست متاكدا من انها
الخطوه النهائيه بل يجب ان نبحث فيما بعد
التوصل الى اتفاق اقوى
وفي لقاء خاص مع العربيه اكد وزير
الخارجيه السعودي فيصل بن فرحانه انا
الولايات المتحده تبقى الحليفه الاقدم
للمملكه لكنه شدد ايضا على اهميه مد
الجسور مع الجميع واشار الى ان المملكه
تعزيز شراكاتها سواء القديمه التاريخيه
والجديده
الحنيف الاقدم والاهم للمملكه العربيه
السعوديه لكن يبقى ايضا مهم ان مده الجسور
مع الجميع وانفتح جميع المملكه العربيه
السعوديه اسرع اقتصاد نمو في العالم هذه
السنه سوف نصل الى اقتصاد تريليون دولار
من الناتج المحلي في نهايه السنه هذه كلها
عناصر اقتصاد الخامس عشر في طريقها الى ان
يكون العاشر او اكبر كل هذه عوامل تفرض
علينا في المملكه العربيه السعوديه ان
نتوسع في شراكاتنا ان نعز الشراكاتنا ليس
فقط الجديده لكن ايضا مع الس- شراكاتنا
القديمه والتاريخيه استاذ نستمر على هذا
المنوال ان شاء الله
واشار وزير الخارجيه السعودي فيصل بن
فرحان ان قمم الرياض كانت قائمه على اسس
راسخه للتعاون مصر
خادم الحرمين الشريفين سمو ولي العهد
والمملكه العربيه السعوديه تبحث عن
الشركاء في كل الاطراف في المرحله الاولى
او في المقام الاول عن مصالحنا لكن نبحث
ايضا عن تحقيق مصالح مشتركه
الصحه الجاسر اهلا بك معنا سيد جاسر يعني
وزير الخارجيه السعودي الامير فيصل بن
فرحان اذن همم قال بانه التوصل الى اتفاق
نووي لا يعني عدم او وجود ضمانات بان
طهران لن تسعى الى انتاج سلاح نووي اي
اتفاق نووي له قيمه في حال لا لم توجد او
تلتزم ايران باي ضمانات بعد عدم امتلاكها
لسلاح النووي ما اهميته
مساء الخير مشكله النظام الايراني تحديدا
ليست فقط مقتصره على سلاح النووي سلاح
النووي تهديد النقل لرفع مستوى المخاطر
الى درجه عاليه في المنطقه سلوك النظام
الايراني سلوك متوحش احدث القلق والخراب
والتوتر وتمزق في المنطقه هي اليوم مسؤوله
عن جميع المشاكل التي موجوده في المنطقه
العربيه هي التي تعمل على اثاره التوتر
والطائفيه
والعمليات الارهابيه فبالتالي مثل هذه
الدوله مثل هذه النظام القائم حاليا بهذه
الصوره هو خطر حقيقي على الاستقرار في
المنطقه ولا يمكن ان يكون الاتفاق النووي
ايا ان يكون المملكه طالب من البدايه ان
اللي اتفقنا انه هو شكل وحاله من الحالات
فقط اذا كان هناك عاليه لعدم امتلاك لكن
هذا النظام سيسال ان يقول لك نحن نشهد ان
هذه ان هذه المحادثات
ماشي هو خير توقفت كانت الولايات المتحده
سبقا قالت انه لم في فبراير سيكون الموعد
الاخير
لاغلاق هذا الملف او اتخاذ قرار الوشاله
نحن همم تقريبا امضيناها اكثر من 10 اشهر
والحاله معلقه مستمره والعمل الايراني في
هذا الجانب مستمر ولذلك تهديد ايران بشكل
حالي قبل ان تمتلك سلاحي تهديد المنطقه
فاذا امتلكت سلاحف بيكون خطورتها اكثر على
المنطقه
المتهور وعدو
اني ومتهم السيد جاسر يعني منذ شهور ونحن
همم
التقادف الاتهامات بين الولايات المتحده
الامريكيه وايران وتشكيك بالنوايه حول من
يفشل العوده الى الارتفاع فعليا بهذه
المرحله ما التنازلات المطلوبه من الطرفين
برايك
الامير فيصل فرحان وضح انه القصه انه مهما
كان ليس لنا نتوقع نتائج ايجابيه حتى في
حال وقت تواصل الاتفاق نووي لسبب انه غياب
نحن هناك الطرفان يتناقشان في موضوع مختلف
تماما قد لا يعني المنطقه بشكل جوهري نحن
نقول الاتفاق النووي حاله وليس كل هناك
ملف كامل لجبلناقش ليس فقط الاتفاق النووي
التالي ما الذي ستقدم ما يتفاصيل لا زالت
المملكه ودور الخليج خارج هذا السياق في
هذه التفاصيل الفنيه المعينه ولا بالتالي
الى مصلحه تحقيق نجاحات معينه قد كليه
لاسباب مختلفه كثيره لكن
هذا لا يحقق ايضانات معينه وبالتالي
الاشكاليه تدور في الوقت الذي تمضي فيه
ايران في تصريح خطواتها باتجاه هذا السلاح
ماذا سيكون حال المنطقه غدا اذا امتلكت
ايران سلاح نووي ماذا سيكون حل الاتفاق لا
ال ال هذا الاتفاقه وعدم الوصول وعدم
اتخاذ خطوات حاسمه تؤدي الى اكتمال
الاتفاق ومن المواصفات معينه تضمن استقرار
المنطقه سيكون بالتالي الفلالات واضح
تماما وهذا ما يحدث الان وهو الخطر
الحقيقي الذي تهدد المنطقه التي ستدفع ان
تكون رغم يعني حصلتها وامنها بكل الطرق في
مواجهه هذه التهديدات وعدم الاتهام او
الاكتكاء على حدود هذا الاتفاق من عدن
شكرا جزيلا لك الكاتب الصحفي جاسر جاسر
حدثنا عبر الهاتف من الرياض
[موسيقى]
ظهرت مقاطع مصوره تعدي ضابط في القوات
الخاصه الايرانيه على امراه اثناء مرورها
في منطقه ستار خان
[موسيقى]
يتعظم قلق اسرائيل من الجبهه الشماليه
التي تشتبك فيها مباشره مع ايران في سوريا
بشقها السوري ولبناني من الجولان
نحن في الجولان المحتل تزداد خشيه اسرائيل
كثيرا في الفتره الاخيره من امكان ان
تستغل ايران مساعدتها للروس في الحرب على
اوكرانيا لجهه تكثيف التموضع الايراني
داخل الجغرافيا السوريه لهذا التوقعات في
اسرائيل بتكثيف الغرض ضد المواقع
الايرانيه الداخله سوريا لكن لا يقلق
اسرائيل اكثر من ذلك حاليا هو محاوله
محتمله من ايران وفقا بعض المصادر الامنيه
في اسرائيل بتهريب
تقنيات اسلحه دقيقه عبر مطار بيروت لصالح
حزب الله ما قد يؤدي في محاوله اعتراض ذلك
الى حرب شامله مع حزب الله على جبهته
لبنان كما سوري سوريا
وفي الوقت الذي تقول في اسرائيل بان ايران
طلبت من روسيا عوده الامور الى ما كانت
عليه قبل العام 2019 اي اطلاق يد ايران
تماما تموضعا ونفودا داخل سوريا وذلك ايضا
بوضع بطاريات دفاع جويه ايرانيه جديده بدل
تلك الروسيه عمليا على الارض بدات اسرائيل
باستعدادات لحرب المحتمله على هذه الجبهه
من قبيل انشاء مناطق عازله كما في هذه
المنطقه في جباته الخشب حيث توغلت اسرائيل
وانشات شوارع امنيه داخل القرى السوريه
وجرفت بعض المزارع اللافت اكثر بان
اسرائيل اعلن عن مناورات عسكريه شامله في
المنطقه الشماليه تحاكم دلاع حرب متعدده
الجبهات زياد حلبي العربيه الجولان المحتل
[موسيقى]
ما ساعه بكين
في علاقات البلدين انطلقت اليوم بزياره
وفد رفيع المستوى ولمده ثلاثه ايام سيجول
الوفد الامريكي في دول المنطقه الصين
وكوريا الجنوبيه واليمن ويتراس الوفد
الامريكي
مساعد وزير الخارجيه لشؤون شرق اسيا
والمحيط الهادئ وكبيره مديرين مجلس الامن
القومي لشؤون الصين وتايوان لورا روزنبرج
[موسيقى]
الاداره الامريكيه ارسال الوفد تنفيذا
للوعد الذي قطعه الشهر الماضي في بالي
الرئيس سان الامريكي والصيني لمحاوله
اعاده العلاقات لطريقها الصحيح حينها اعلن
الرئيسان ان الدولتين ستواصلان اداره
المنافسه بين البلدين بشكل مسئوله
واستكشاف مجالات التعاون المحتمله في
الاثناء سيعد الوفد الامريكي لزياره وزير
الخارجيه انصن بلينكن للصين المقرره اوائل
العام المقبل والتي ستكون الاولى من نوعها
لدبلوماسي امريكي بارز منذ اربع سنوات
وتحدث بيضا وشي خصوصا عن مواضيع خلافيه
منها مستقبل سيوان والقيود الامريكيه على
واردات المنتجات التقنيه الصينيه
التوترات بين امريكا والصين تصعدت
مشاهدينا ببطئ منذ عقود لكنها ارتفعت بشكل
كبير بعد ان شلنا الرئيس الامريكي السابق
دونالد ترامب حربا تجاريه حمائيه معصيه
ومنذ توليه منصبه العام الماضي لم يفعل
بيضن الكثير لعكس سياسات ترامب التجاريه
وخلال اجتماعهما الشهر الماضي ابدا
الرئيسان الصيني والامريكي رغبتهما في
تفادي تحول المنافسه بينهما الى نزاع
التوافق الظاهر بين شي وبيضن لا يمنع وجود
خلافات اكبر لعل من ابرزها ملف تايوان
فعلها مش قمه مجموعه ال 20 حضر الرئيس
الصيني واشنطن من انبيكينا تعتبر تايوان
خطا احمر يجب عدم تخطيها وسائل الاعلام
صينيه نقلت عن شيء قوله ان مساله تايوان
في صميم المصالح الجوهريه للصين والقاعده
للاساس السياسي للعلاقات الصينيه
الامريكيه حينها قال الرئيس الامريكي ان
افعال الصين العدوانيه بشان تايوان تعرض
السلام للخطر في المنطقه
محور وجدل الاخر في العلاقه بين الدولاتين
هو محاوله الولايات المتحده اعاقه الصين
في المجال التقنيه الرئيس الامريكي جو
بايدن وقع في اغسطس الماضي الرقائق
الالكترونيه المسمى اختصارا بتشيبس ووعد
بمليارات الدولارات في شكل حوافز واعانات
لتعزيز انتاج اشباه الموصلات على الاراضي
الامريكيه
بموجب القانون تمنع الشركات الاجنبيه من
بيع اشباه الموصلات المتطوره ومعدات تصنيع
الرقائق للشركات الصينيه كما قد يواجه
المواطنون الامريكيون والمقيمون فيها
عقوباتن اذا تعاملوا مع الشركات الصينيه
وفقا للقواعد الجديده لكن هل ستتحدث
القيود هذه تاثيرا على الصناعات الصينيه
بحسب مختصين التاثير سيكون وقتيا فقط ففي
مقابله صحيفه فاينل شيل تايمز قال الرئيس
التنفيذي لشركه ان اي سي اليابانيه
للتقنيه با كا يوكي موريتا ان تاثير
العقوبات مؤقت بينما سيستمر وجود الصين
بقوه في مجال الذكاء الاصطناعي واعتبر
المسؤول الياباني انه من غير الممكن تجاه
القدره التنافسيه للصين في التكنولوجيا
وانها ستصبح واحده من القوى التي يحسب لها
حساب على المدى الطويل مريضه اضاف ان بعض
المجالات قد تشهد انخفاضا في سرعه
التطورها الا ان ذلك لن يقف البحث
والتطوير في الصين ولن يكون بالامكان
اعاقتها تقنيه كما حدث سابقا مع الاتحاد
السوفيتي
[موسيقى]
تتابعونا معنا ولكن بعض الفاصل
قصف روسي بمسيرات ايرانيه واكثر من مليون
ونصف المليون شخص في منطقه اوديسا بلا
كهرباء
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديده على مختلف الجبهات
يستمر القتال بين القوات الروسيه
والاوكرانيه على اراضي الاخيره شرقا
وجنوبا وزاره الدفاع الروسيه اعلنت اليوم
عن احباط هجوم اوكراني في جنوب دونات قتل
خلاله 40 جنديا اوكرانيا كما كشفت الوزاره
عن تنفيذ ضربات جديده ضد مواقع اوكرانيه
في كل من حركات ومحور كوبيانسكار
في انظمه اطلاق صواريخ جراده في مدينه
سليمان
24 ساعه هيئه الاركان الاوكرانيه حذرت من
ان روسيا تحشد قواتها في لوغانس بكثافه
وتستعد لمهام قتاليه واشارت الى ان خطر
الهجمات الصاروخيه الروسيه على البنيه
التحتيه لا يزال قائمه على الناحيه الاخرى
اكدت سلطات دونات في المواليه لروسيا ان
رانيا استهدفت المقاطعه ب 180 قذيفه
وصاروخا خلال 24 ساعه كما اتهمت السلطات
المواليه لروسيا دوناتس القوات الاوكرانيه
بقصف مركز على المدينه ب 20 صاروره
[موسيقى]
الطائرات المسيره الانتحاريه عادت لتحلق
في اجواء اوكرانيا هذه المره فوق مدينه
اوديسا مسؤولون اوكرانيون اشار الى ان
الكهرباء انقطعت عن جميع مرافق البنيه
التحتيه غير الحيويه في المدينه الساحليه
جنوب اوكرانيا بعد اطلاق روسيا طائرات
مسيره لقصف منشاتين الطاقه
روسيه بطائرات مسيره تركت مليون ونصف
المليون نسمه بلا كهرباء في منزلقه
ايرانيه الصنع تم اسقاطها اثناء الغاره
الروسيه بينما وصلت خمس طائرات اخرى
لهدفها ما الحق اضرار جسيمه بالبنيه
التحتيه الطاقه وفي الاثناء حذرت مصلحه
الكهرباء المحليه في اوديسا من ان تصليح
الاعطال قد يستغرق اسابيع وربما يصل ثلاثه
شهور بدوره قال حاكم اوديس ماكسيم ماشينكو
ان البنيه التحتيه الضروريه فقط والمتعلقه
بالمستشفيات تم تزويدها بالكهرباء مشيرا
الى ان الوضع لا يزال صعبا لكنه تحت
السيطره نذكر اخيرا بان الرئيس الروسيب
لديمير بوتن تعهد يوم الخميس
بالاستمرار في ضرب شبكه الطاقه الاوكرانيه
رغم صيحات الاستنكار الدوليه ضد الهجمات
التي تركت ملايين الاشخاص فريسه للبرد
والظلام
[موسيقى]
ارتقى عاليا في الهواء ليرفع بلاده الى
مربع الذهبي في كاس العالم
نتحدث عن يوسف النصيري مهاجم المنتخب
المغربي
وكتيبه اسود الاطلس اسمهم اسم بلادهم
والعرب وافريقيا بين افضل اربع منتخبات في
العالم انصيري اصبح اول لاعب مغربي يسجل
في نسختين من كاس العالم
وسجل المهاجم هدف الفوز الوحيد على
البرتغال في ربع نهائي قطر
20-20 وسبق ليوسف انصيري ان دخل التاريخ
مره اخرى سابقا حين سجل امام كندا واصبح
اول لاعب مغربي يسجل مثل ما ذكرنا في
نسختين مختلفتين اغلى بطولات كره القدم
لنتعرف عليها اكثر ولد هذا الشاب يوسف
انصيري في الاول من يونيو عام
1997 بدا مسيرته في شوارع وازقه مدينته
فاس التي انضم الى فريقها نادي المغرب
الفاسي
اعين مكتشفي المواهب رات يوسف انصيري الذي
انتقل عام 2015 لنادي ملجا الاسباني الذي
قدم بين صفوفه ثلاث سنوات الرحله
الاسبانيه لنصير استمرت بانتقاله الى نادي
ليجانس صيف 2018 واستمر معه لموسم ونصف
فقط تالقه دفع بنادي اشبيليه للاستثمار به
والحصول على موهبته في يناير من عام 2020
اما مع المنتخب فقد بدا مسيره يوسف او
بدات هذه المسيره بالظهور امام البانيا
والديا
المشاركه في كاس الامم الافريقيه في نفس
العام يوسف النصيري لعب 54 مباراه في
مسيرته الدوليه مع المنتخب المغربي وسجل
بها 16 هدفا
ربما فيها هو هدف الامس الذي منح المغرب
بطاقه العبور الى نصف نهائي كاس العالم في
قطر
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
في الاردن وقفوا اضراب مالكي الحافلات
والسيارات العموميه وسيارات الاجره بعد
[موسيقى]
اهلا بكم من جديد اربع مباريات
كاس العالم لكره القدم
الذي يتصدر ترتيب هدافي البطوله بخمسه
اهداف اللاعب البالغ من العمر 23 عاما سجل
هدفا في مرمى استراليا في المباراه
الافتتاحيه لفريقه قبل ان يهز الشباك
الدانمارك بهدفين المباراه الثانيه ثم عدم
هدفين امام منتخب بولندا في الدوري الثاني
المركز الثاني
للهدافين
يتقسمه لاعبا الارجنتينيون المسي والفرنسي
اوليفييو برصيد اربعه اهداف لكل منهما
افتتح ميسي عدد اهدافه من نقطه الجزاء في
المباراه التي خسرها امام السعوديه بينما
جاء الهدف الثاني امام المكسيك في الدوري
الاول في الدوري اللاحقين سجل ميسي هدفا
امام استراليا كما هز شبه كلندا بدور
الثمانيه نختتم مع اوليفياجيرو صاحب
الاهداف الاربعه مثل ميسي المهاجم الفرنسي
احرز ثنائيه في مرمى استراليا بدور
المجموعات قبل ان يسجل هدفا امام بولندا
في الدوري الثاني ويوم امس سجل جيرو هدف
فوز فرنسا على انجلترا في دور الثمانيه
ليقوده منتخب الديوك للمربع الذهبي
[موسيقى]
اعلنت هيئه وتنظيم قطاع النقل البري في
الاردن عن توصلها الاتفاق مع النقابه
العامه لملكه الحافلات الاردنيه والنقابه
العامه لاصحاب السيارات العموميه وسيارات
الاجره على استمرار وزياده تقديم الدعم
النقدي لكافه انماط نقل الركاب في البلاد
ضمن اختصاص الهيئه وجاء هذا الاتفاق بعد
لقاء عقد في وزاره النقل مع نقابتين
وممثلين عن القطاع تم خلاله التداول في
زياده الدعم النقدي لقطاع نقل الركاب
مقابل عدم رفع اجور النقل على المواطنين
وتقرر وقف كافه اشكال الاضراب في هذا
القطاع مقابل زياده الدعم النقدي لمده
ثلاثه اشهر
مراجعتها وتجديدها الدوريا
حول هذا الموضوع ينضم الينا من عمان عامر
الشوبكي الباحث في شؤون النفط والطاقه
اهلا بك سيد عامر يعني خلال الحلقه فك
الاعتصاب كان صار له اكثر من يوم ما الذي
حصل
وما التسويات التي وضعت لكي يتم فكهالاطسه
اصحاب الباصات ومركبات نقل الركاب هذا امر
جيد لان هذا الامر تسبب في عدم قدره
العديد من الموظفين او الطلاب الوصول الى
اماكن عملهم وبالتالي هنالك ايضا مازال
يعني اعتصام او اضراب لاصحاب الشاحنات في
العديد من المناطق في الاردن 20,000 شاحنه
كانت تعاني في الفتره الماضيه سواء من
الاضطرابات السياسيه في العراق او في
سوريا تقطعت سبل او امكانيه وصولهم الى
المناطق اخرى سواء في سوريا في لبنان في
تركيا
وبذلك تم التضييق عليهم الاردن في الواقع
يعيش في حاله حصار غير معلن داخليا هذا
الامر ايضا كانوا يعتمدون على اسعار
الوقود للنقل الداخلي بعد الارتفاع الذي
جرى مؤخرا على اسعار الوقود اضطر هؤلاء
المعتصمون الى اظهار مشكله قم بشكل اكبر
طبعا اسعار الوقود الان في الاردن مرتفعه
وهي همم لاعلى عربيه نعم
طيب سيد عامر يعني اصحاب الشاحنات ما هي
مطالبهم الان
حصر في تخفيض اسعار الوقود لان هذا الامر
الحكومه يعني تعتقد بانه صعب عليها اعتمدت
الحكومه بشكل كبير على الضرائب المتاديه
من الوقود تفرض الحكومه يعني في الاسعار
الموجوده حاليا نسب ضريبه مرتفعه تصل الى
25% على السولار ومن 68% الى 95% على
اصناف البنزين هذا يعني يؤمن لها دخل معين
للحكومه نهايه العام وبالتالي هذه الاسعار
ايضا جعلت الاسعار في الاردن على العربيه
وغير متناسبه مع دخل المواطن هذا ايضا سبب
الحكومه الاردنيه اسعار الطاقه مع مستوى
لا يتحمله دخل المواطن الاردني يعني كيف
تفعل ذلك على اي اسس
اعتقد بانه خطا رفع اسعار المحروقات
والوقود الضروريه عصب الحياه خاصه الديزل
لهذه النسب او فرض ضريبه عليها وبالتالي
يعني هي اعتمدت بشكل مفروط متزايد في
السنوات الاخيره حتى فرضت في العام 2019
ما يسمى الضريبه الثابته المقطوعه لتضمن
في نهايه كل عام مليار و250 مليون دينار
يعني ايرادات من الضريبه المفروضه على
الوقود وهذا يشكل تقريبا ربع الايرادات
الضريبيه للحكومه الاعتماد بشكل مفرد كان
خطا كبير لكن يعني لم تجد الحكومه ايرادات
اخرى غريبه وبالتالي هذا ايضا خطا اخر
للحكومه ما اصحاب السيارات
التي حله الاضراب الذي قام به هل يمكن ان
نرى اضرابا اخر يعني المشكله حلت بشكل
جذري
اعتقد ان المشكله لم تحل بشكل جذري واعتقد
بانه ايضا تم اعداء ان يشابه هذا الاعلان
في الاسبوع الماضي واعلن يضربون بانهم غير
يعني لا ينطون تحت سياسه نقابتهم وبالتالي
هذا سنراه غدا اتمنى ان ينتهي بعض
الاعتصامات والاضطرابات خاصه على قطاع
النقل الذي قد يشل الحركه في الاردن وقطاع
الشحن الذي له نتائج كارثيه ايضا على
الاقتصاد الاردني على المعادلات التضخم
وربما فقدان بعض السلع وعدم قدره الانتاج
الاردني منتجات الاردنيه الغذائيه
والصناعيه للوصول الى بناء العقبه او خارج
الاردن شكرا
الباحث في شؤون النفط والطاقه
[موسيقى]
كشف تقرير صادر عن منصه عن ازاله ملايين
الحسابات المزيفه التي كانت فيها الشركه
اعلنت انه تم ازاله اكثر من 21 مليون حساب
في الفتره بين بدايه العام وحتى نهايه
يونيو الماضي اضافت الشركه ان 95% من
الحسابات الوهميه تمت ازالتها بواسطه
ادوات مؤتمه حيث رصدت الشركه زياده بنسبه
28% بعدد الحسابات المزيفه على الانسان
[موسيقى]
اثار عرضه وثائقي عن الامير هاري وزوجته
ماجن ماركل على منصه نتفليكس اثر الكثير
من الانتقادات وقد شنت عدد من الصحف
البريطانيه هجوما على الثنائي وذهب البعض
الى حد وصفي ما جرى بالخيانه الملكيه
الاسبوعين الماضيين لم يهدا هذا القصر قصر
باكنهم فما لبثت ان تنطوي حادثه العنصريه
التي طالت مساعده الملكه اليزابيث الرحله
حتى اعلنت منصه نتفليكس عن وثائقها روماجن
هذا الوثائقي الذي تصدر عناوين الصحف كافه
بلا استثناء وهو ما قد يتسبب بصداع
للعائله الملكيه التي عاده ما تتجنب
الحديث في امور العائله الخاصه
يمثل حلقات الثلاثه الاولى لا تقلوا عن
ضجه الاعلان الترويجي الذي تزامن مع
زيارتي ويليام وكيت الى امريكا فاراء
الثنائي في العائله الملكه ستنفرت مؤيدها
لاسيما في وسائل الاعلام
صحيفه المترو ذائعه الصيت والتي توزع في
القطارات سنه هجوما عنيفا على هاري وماجد
سائله اياهما هل تضعان المال قبل العائله
واجابت عنهما قائله انه السؤال الذي لن
يجيب عنه
صحيفه الديلي اكسبريس
والملك الراحله طلبت بايقاف ما وصفته
بالخيانه للملكه الديل ميل وادي
ضربه الراحله في حين تحدثت التايمز عن
انزعاج القصر من الوثائق ومعتضمنه
كينج
من ملاحقه الاعلام لها بحجه ان هذا ما
يحدث لكل اللواتي يرتبطن بالعائله ويتحدث
هاريا فخره بان اطفاله مختلطوا العرق وكيف
انه فعل مثل ماذا وترك كل شيء لاجلها
النقمه على العائله حيث تقول انها مهما
فعلت كانوا شيء يجدون طريقه لتدميرها في
الوثائقي يبدو هاري ماخودا بوالدته وبتشبه
بينها وبينما من حيث التعاطف والحنان ومن
حيث الثقه والدفء هل يقول انه سيفعل ما
بيوسعه لتجنب تكرار سيناري والدته مع
عائلته الحاليه هو لا يريد للتاريخ ان
يعيد نفسه وربما ذلك هو المفتاح الذي
ادخله القلوب الكثيرين الذين احبه دائما
[موسيقى]
صوره اليوم مشاهدينا ستبقى دائما ودائما
لكارثه البرتغال في كاس العالم انها صوره
بكاء رونالدو خرج من الملعب باكيا حزينا
كما لم يشاهده عشاق كره القدم من قبل وخرج
اليوم في رساله هي الاولى بعد الخساره من
المغرب قائلا وداعا لاكبر احلام اضافه لم
قدر وجهي ابدا في القتال ولم افقد الامل
في هذا الحلم للاسف انتهاء الحلم بالامس
فقط اريدكم ان تعلموا جميعا ان هناك
الكثير قد قيل و كتب لكن التزامى للبرتقال
لم يتغير ولو للحظه دائما
زملائي او لبلادي
تصريح اليوم هو للمتحدث باسم الكرام
الهندي قال ان العلاقه بين روسيا والغرب
وصلت الى مرحله المواجهه وقال ردا على
سؤال بشان الى اين وصلت العلاقه بين روسيا
والغرب فقال نحن لا نتحرك لقد وصلنا
بالفعل الى محطه تسمى المواجهه وعلينا ان
نكون متحفظين و اقوياء
اما فيديو اليوم وهو من ايران مقطع فيديو
انتشر على منصات التواصل يظهر ايرانيات
يقاومنا نساء شرطه الاخلاق
ويطربوهن من حافله في طهران فقالت سيدتان
صورتا مقطع الفيديو نخله حجابنا كل يوم
ولا نقبل التنمر من شرطه الاخلاق سننهي
النظام الفصل العنصري بين الجنسين اللفت
مشاهدينا هو ظهور شرطه الاخلاق بعد اعلان
السلطات الايرانيه حلها ووقفه تسير ما
تسميها بدوريته الادب
[تصفيق]
ملفاتنا لليوم المزيد من الاخبار
والتحليلات زوروا العربيات
ننتقل الى اخبار الساعه اليوم مع الزميل
عادل ايضا كيفك يا عادل
تفضل شكرا جزيلا لك بالتاكيد سنكون على
موعد مع معرفه هذه الاضطرابات والاحتجاجات
في ايران كيف اثرت على العمله وبالتالي
ايضا المواجهه المحتمله ايضا بين روسيا
والغرب
[موسيقى]